il y a trois jours c'est au domaine de
windsor que le prince philippe nous a
quittés après presque cent ans de vie
c'est pas un tweet officiel de la
famille royale que la disparition du
prince philippe 99 ans a été révélé
époux de la reine elizabeth ii il a
traversé à ses côtés tous les grands
moments de l'histoire contemporaine de
la grande bretagne
c'est le 20 novembre 1947 qu'il dit oui
à la queen et devient officiellement le
prince consort du royaume uni philippe
batel n'a pas vraiment le pedigree
parfait prince certes mais désargentés
ce samedi aura lieu l'inhumation du
prince philippe lors d'un événement très
organisée après le college of arms si
son cercueil ne sera pas exposé au
public
la cérémonie se déroulera à la chapelle
saint georges avant d'être enterrés dans
les jardins du manoir de froch mort
propose déjà la reine victoria le prince
albert il était depuis presque sept
décennies de piliers de la reine celui
qui lui a permis de tenir dans toutes
les épreuves
et bertrand decker c'est avec no mercy
bertrand écrivain journée il s'est
surtout spécialiste de la monarchie
bon sans merci d'être là alors c'est
vrai que la nouvelle de la mort du
prince philippe forcément au royaume uni
ont pas encore plus que ça c'est un
énorme événement enfin et c'est une
énorme tristesse non souvenez vous de la
série ce de crohn inquiète impopulaire
au royaume uni il faut savoir que la
monarchie est vraiment le ciment de
l'institution il considère vraiment la
famille royale comme leur propre famille
comme une partie de leur propre famille
rire vous le disais ça fait soixante
quatorze ans que le prince philippe est
aux côtés de la reine qu'ils sont mariés
donc la majorité des anglais à l'heure
actuelle n'a quasiment jamais connu que
le prince fils et je ne sais c'est un
truc de fou alors avait avec le décès du
prince philippe beaucoup ont découvert
un homme cache marron borderline limite
ils sont au point peur je vous donnais
des citations à venir me dire si c'était
le prince philippe ou six étaient libres
candeloro qui a dit des femmes ne savent
pas cuisiner les prêts il a dit ça oui
y avait il parlé des femmes britten les
fans serait une déclaration qu'il avait
faite gratuitement comme ça 30
il avait un côté très viril match au
havre
en effet à côté vikings il est prince
aussi danois aussi par naissance prince
de grèce et de dalmat recherché et c'est
vrai qu'il avait quand même le côté un
peu traditionnelle et rigide que peut
avoir la monarchie du siècle dernier
peut-être en tout cas c'est une page qui
se tourne a maintenant avec le décès du
prince philippe a probablement rentrer
dans une autre
on a vu on a vu la reine elizabeth
verser une petite larmichette bao est
pas fou c'était pas voilà on l'a pas vu
si j'ai vu moi la pleurer mais chez moi
regarder
elle était sûre tpm peu regardez
regardez regardez météo on a vu qu'une
seule fois pleurer la reine
quant à la dia diouf britannia wee cc à
west ham et moi depuis toujours que moi
je 95 en tentant même jour absolument
mais j'espère que parce que auditions
vont dans league mike plus comme ça
ensuite depuis créé traditionnel un pas
qu'ont l'un par oui et j'espère que ça
va laver sa mère est décédée à 102 en
est encore une petite marche le mineur
vieillissent bien et ouais c'est vrai
lui ont béni cela non mais sérieux qui a
dit à un adolescent qui rêve d qui rêvé
d'être astronaute tu ne pourras jamais
volé tué trop gros mais profite lui
aussi philippe c'est un gosse de 13 ans
qu'il avait rencontrée et fait part de
son rêve émigrer vérité effectivement il
ya plein de phrase quand même qu'ils
sont borderline et bordoy mais je trouve
que les hommages à l'image des phrases
que vous sortez les hommages ont été
très unanime on n'aura peut-être plus
des normes auxquelles tu meurs tu gardes
le meilleur oui mais toi quand tu vas
mourir ça est très court
[Applaudissements]
pensez à vous parce qu'un jour ils
recevaient des dignitaires russes de
très haut niveau et d'être dit ouais bon
je vais les recevoir mais quand même
c'est bah tu as raison tu es tout mes
ancêtres et c'est vrai que comme il les
descendants des romanov
aussi sommes donc oui je sais la
sélection qui a apprécié filmé à des
phrases qui sont vraiment terribles
allemagne en effet aujourd'hui d'autres
étrangers a dit à une personne en
fauteuil roulant combien de personnes
avez vous écraser avec votre truc
oui il a dit ça il a dit ça lors de son
80e anniversaire avec tous les vétérans
qui était l'unique en main puisqu'il et
me dit le monsieur est il a quand même
dit vous savez le pire c'est pas de
fêter son 80e anniversaire c'est pas
vieillir c'est de devoir supporter des
cérémonies et des gens comme vous et où
ce mec-là qui a dit alors lui et qu'on
sait que gill qui a dit y ait une troupe
de danseurs africains on va dire que
c'est lui battant mais ils ont arrêté le
jeu parce que c'était de la merde
vous êtes tous de la même famille le
samedi ça je le savais et ces mêmes ils
disent à un lord un lord anglais qu'il
voit il dit mais vous venez de vous
venez d'où avec toute votre famille et
le gars lui dit je viens de birmingham
qui est une grande ville anglaise
d'incroyable franchement c'était ça
aussi le prince philippe est illégal
faire ce que l'on pourrait peut-être
dire aussi c'est vrai mais que depuis
cinquante-deux depuis le couronnement de
la reine il est à côté de la reine c'est
le premier de ces sujets il lui jure
fidélité et boris johnson l'a reconnu en
dix ans nous avons une dette envers le
prince philip c'est à dire que il navré
pour la couronne donc d'un vrai pour
l'angleterre alors c'est vrai il y à ce
que tes gars forts mais surtout il ya ce
côté bo sort à ce que chez les windsor
cette monnaie avec une petite cuillère
d'argent dans la bouche a blagué même en
argent massif on voyage beaucoup
énormément et on estime quand même que
le prince philippe a quand même rempli
va 2000 engagements officiels au cours
de sa carrière a aidé à bosser quand
même labo s'investir bosseur et va
manquer ou pas il va manquer oui
indéniablement parce que vous savez si
c'est la reine qui porte la couronne en
angleterre c'est le prince philip qui
porte la culotte quoi moi vraiment il
est le chef de clan c'est ce qu'a fait
moi
non c'est vrai elle a un peu femme
soumise mais pas du tout obama a prôné
un truc ah oui mais j'étais chez glam à
devenir sur claren moi je me suis dit
elle doit visiter nos pauvres doit être
micheline entre-temps oui mais est-ce
qu'il était un fidèle parce qu'il ya des
rumeurs d'infidélité du prince ans et
les danseuses et qu'il était victime
globe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous avoue que je n'ai pas dans la
chambre à coucher un break c'est vrai on
parle de ces femmes club du jeudi alors
les clubs du jeu et rendez vous c'était
la haute aristocratie les membres de
l'armée des militaires qui se
rejoignaient est en effet il ya des noms
qui circulent et il a light à acheter
absolument pas harcèlement quoi parce
que dans la haute aristocratie oui c'est
un peu de coutume manque énorme et c'est
à dire que sa part obligé nachi dignité
elle a en revanche exigé la loyauté mais
loyal il l'a toujours dit
donc loyal c'est bon quelle est la
dépense trop la loyauté
titi déloyale je vous fais que ça qu'il
est loyal
[Rires]
oui il paraît qu'avec la reine il
faisait chambre à part depuis des années
c'est vrai toujours beaucoup mais
william et kate font chambre à part
c'est le secret d'un mariage un musicien
donc tu ne vois jamais la brosse à dents
de l'autre non c'est vrai avant on
disait madame barrière c'est vrai et les
salles mais c'est beau et steevy boulay
fait une très belle entrée abattoir à
tadu amer et les mecs c'est là que je
vois notre niveau à télomères steevy
boulay est arrivé au téléphone à
l'académie
il va falloir qu'on se posait botella à
witikon qui est un grand amoureux et
bien vous rendez compte quand même
qu'elle a rencontré pour la première
fois elle avait 8 ans n'en avais 13 il
se retrouve quelques années après elle
tombe amoureuse de lui et le mari
quelques années après il était un peu
précurseur aussi puisque c'est eux qu'on
crée le buzz lors de leur mariage
puisque ça a été retransmis sur la bbc
donc c'était un mariage ou right royal
de mise en grèce buzz avant le buzz et
jean pascal en géo poser des questions
sur justement la royauté
quand la reine fini son dîner tout le
monde doit s'arrêter demandé oui mais
bien passé jean michel cohen c'est sous
la mairie va manger avec la reine des
calottes ces mots qui termine oui et
bien pour ce faire elle a une petite
salade qui est posée à côté d'elle elle
ne termine jamais vraiment manger elle
va jouer dans sa salade la boxe à vous
permettre mais c'est lorsqu'on va lui
donner le signal d'arrêter de jouer dans
sa salle à qu'elle va mieux on y
trouvera des comptes elle arrête de
jouer là on arrête tous de me lasser le
feu vert qui est donné alors on passe au
cloud après la famille royale ne peut
pas jouer au monopoly c'est vrai tuerie
pas que ça joue vicieux source de
disputes au sein de la famille parce
qu'on parle jamais d'argent ils n'ont
pas d'argent ils n'ont pas de contact
avec l'argent il ne connaissait pas la
valeur de l'argent qu'elle bien docteur
maboule hilton lors d'un déplacement les
membres de la famille emprunt en portent
tous une tenue s'est déroulé des
familles
c'est vrai pourquoi parce qu'en cas de
deuil inopinés doit être un devoir avoir
une tenue noire et un brasseur c'est
incroyable ce seuil par la famille
royale a interdiction de manger des
fruits de mer
c'est vrai en présence de la reine
uniquement parce que ben voilà c'est
difficile à manger des fruits de mer il
faut déplacer tout cela donc voilà est
alors aussi intégrant également les
tomates et les petits pois noms et les
escargots parce que wallace a créé par
kwh alors elle mange pas de tomates et
petit point là ils n'ont l'arraisonnage
les gens les connards annonce escargots
c'est dangereux avec souvenez-vous de la
ram exploite petits pois de tomates
s'amuse pas tous les ouvrages chez les
windsor c'est pas non plus la folie tu
m'aurais dit elle mange pas de ma croûte
dorée des mollahs mais là il est
formellement interdit à buckingham
palace pourquoi baleines pour le
protocole aweys or ils doivent sentir
hyper bon delachaux de la laine bah
voilà et alors et pour la petite
anecdote aussi puisqu'on parle de
l'année le prince charles a inventé lui
même un appareil à qui lui permet de
s'extraire le dentifrice de son tube à
dentifrice jusqu'à la décline yalu peut
le mettre dans ses oreilles annoncé en
mars que les winners sont quand même un
peu avant l icd barils sont très riches
cela qu'on me paie cela boostera pris
nommément
bon c'est pas tout mais à peu près on
peut pas savoir excellent on dit parfois
que sont peut-être les plus riches du
monde bah oui c'est oui oui il faut de
l'état de la fortune privée et
personnelle
pour la petite histoire buckingham
palace féminine soeur appartiennent à
l'état mais les deux autres propriétés
dont jeannie la reine donc balles rue
d'ham sont des pros
contre elle mais des pavillons en
location
oui mais alors que hier c'est vrai ah
ouais ouais si la reine positionne son
sac sur son bras droit séquelle de
mettre fin une conversation
ouais je crois que c'est vrai ah oui si
c'est vrai que c'est vrai oui et alors
sierre elle commence à jouer avec son
alliance c'est qu'elle est
particulièrement belle à tout le monde
dégage
oui c'est vrai à sa tâche son alliance
est mort c'est où ça chiale et pain pour
conduire un véhicule elizabeth ii n'est
pas obligé d'avoir son permis de
conduire ah bah ça paraît que c'est la
seule royaume uni ne pas trop qu'il est
à 95 en plateau elle conduit encore
montrée courageuse entier de mégane ou
la reine d'angleterre
la guerre est conduisait plus depuis un
accident si dans la drôme alors qu'ils
étaient gravissimes et aurait pour la
petite anecdote aussi bien samedi
le corbillard qui va transporter la
dépouille royale a été dessiné par le
prince lui-même était dans le féru de
voiture la première fois que l'on va
voir ce fric
[Applaudissements]